alors on va jouer vous allez jouer tous
contrefaçon d'accord ou alors premier
jeu il y avait plein de jeux dans le
bigdil bill est ce que tu peux nous
expliquer le premier jeu c'est pas ça
qui va animer prépaiement on a vu cyril
mon ami vincent le premier se s'appelle
la montagne de sucre ap
le but du jeu est d'empiler sur un seul
morceau de sucre le plus de sucre
possible attention vous ne pouvez pas
jouer si vous êtes allé ensuite au
gluten
[Musique]
alors évidemment celui qui fait tomber
la colonne de sucre a perdu perdu elle
rassure tu vas jouer contre quelqu'un
choisis ton adversaire et marine marine
marine tu paries sur qui parce qu'il ya
un très beau cadeau à gagner qu'elle un
premier cadeau l'égérie sucre santé
faire tourner j'avais choisi emballé
mais non c'est entre 20 sont hagards du
produisent à elles trois
il te reste de ce que tu as fumé hier
soir vincent lagaf valérie benaïm
alexandre vincent lagaf
elle joue pour quelques ados les chéris
elle va jouer pour un très beau premier
cadeau puisque tu vas jouer pour une
enceinte sans fil alors et après il y
aura le rideau et il est interdit de
mettre un coup de pompe dans la table
datacore non c'est pas mon genre attaché
à leonard aude impose le premier
bâtiment n'ont mis le casque à votre
tour tu peut le poser comme je fais
comme tu veux et le building
il faisait 11 millions de
téléspectateurs accepter tout et j'adore
ça mais on a la pression c'est pal aller
trop vite
vous connaissez bien galéré et vincent
ouais ouais on a un peu bricolé sur une
chaîne avec la perceuse à toi
je sais plus quelle émission on a effet
on avait fait la millième on avait fait
pas mal de choses et étaient venus aussi
sur drôle de jeu dont le jour c'était
vraiment amusé l'aller sur drôle de
bullet man et oui sur sakho tiéné ttp
combien verts ont pu déguster fond et on
est bien là on est pas mal là pas mal ça
peut durer un à l'ehess
je vais rajouter un autre cadeau parce
que comme c'est très long je vais
rajouter en plus si tu gagnes tu as dit
valérie japon ce lundi valérie
d'attention à la dimension
je rajoute une machine à café studio à à
elle est là pour aider la mairie allait
bien aller masi à l'ailé
voilà on est là qui va gagner entre
vincent tu gagnes déjà la machine à café
et tu gagnes également une enceinte son
fils on va jouer maintenant pour un
smartphone pourquoi vous avez menées sur
valérie voilà les parier sur vania
oui oui valérie ouais c'est vrai
on va dire qu'elle avait travaillé son
attention va jouer maintenant contre
kelly on va jouer chez moi vous vous
montrez dans l'émission il monte révélé
le fait est là pour faire la guerre fait
on va jouer quelques passants kelly
commandant dans le speed mouchoirs jong
il on dirait pas comme ça mais c'est
très dur de vider une boîte de mouchoirs
en papier moi le premier qui arrive
gagner le jeu attention vous ne pouvez
utiliser qu'une seule manche oui on doit
l'excellent doit on doit impérativement
enlever ou choix un parent et tu peux
préparer le premier attention je peux
préparer le premier c'est le premier qui
vit de la boîte marine marine dakota
mois avec marine tu paries sur qui mal
qui lie sur qui il a l'air d'avoir
l'habitude sur kelly temps des sucres
aussi je veux juste jouer au mois de
mars a été surtout paru sur kelly tony
d'accord apparemment tu vas perdre
attention pourquoi deux étapes
et une baie olala aller travailler très
fort elle a tellement plu répondez quoi
[Applaudissements]
je
kelly it again également avocat
smartphones on va jouer maintenant pour
un ordinateur à bord d'un vol bigdil
ailleurs le même merdier que j'avais
fait on va jouer pour un ordinateur
portable et après il y aura le rideau un
ordinateur portable qui mettra le plus
de canettes mais c'est quoi ce jeu c'est
le saut à leucan est de canal canal
cannelle ou also les gazaouis un cyril
benjamin et géraldine un truc s'était
jamais vu aussi bons dans les points
c'est bon dans cette émission on peut la
perdre y avoir d'autres
[Applaudissements]
but du jeu est de former entre deux
personnes la plus longue file de
canettes on ajoute les canettes une par
une les premiers qui font tomber leurs
canettes sont éliminés il était garde
des sceaux j'ai quand même un lac salé
premier du fait tomber les canettes les
prairies accompli alors je les connais
tu sais pas avec qui on joue 20 qu'il a
fait on va jouer normalement lagaf
contre cyril lagaf et cyril donc toi et
moi qu'outre benjamin gérald d'accord on
va le faire la gaffe et moi alors le but
du jeu il est très simple on se met face
à face dans nos équipes ont mis une
première canette comme celui de sièges
attention je le promets qu'il fait
tomber laquelle elle a perdu la vie
alors on joue avec des canettes vides à
l'époque
ah oui bah oui on joue avec des canettes
pcb soeur n'est aujourd'hui avant jeu
avec des canettes vides
sa part que les mesures annoncées par
mme vasseur de quoi vivent à côté d'eux
a joué donc pour adopter un ca de la
nurses porte à 90 un portable comme ça
c'est toi qui tombent à paris c'est
comme ça que c'est bien à l'épave touche
pas d'accord en fait un croche-patte jeu
sans combattre
[Musique]
vas-y attend on et comment là on est
comment vois tu sais pas bien c'est pas
bien eh bien non ah oui on est bien
mieux maintenant
pour l'instant au début aurait recul
pense pas pour l'instant du mal tu
bouges et oui oui d'accord auquel m il a
raté pas bien la paix l'amitié
j'attends que j'ai toujours tiré
d'affaires
les benjamins n'ont pas su retourner
dans la gueule ne t'inquiète pas on s'en
est bien ailleurs les palio la manne toi
jamais vu mais normalement
[Applaudissements]
oui oui bien ce match cheryl et voulant
arrêter chez encore deux traites sur la
veille sa chérie ma chérie tu as gagné
pour l'instant aucun smartphone ou un
ordinateur portable ainsi que tu peux
nous dire je garde tous les cadeaux ou
bien vincent qu'est ce qui se passait le
grid alors chacha soit la possibilité de
repartir avec cette somme de cadeaux
tout de suite maintenant à la fin de
l'émission ou alors tu peux te dire que
il ya boat est beaucoup plus gros à
gagner et pour ça je te propose de
prendre le rideau mais attention les
bouderies des marines attention derrière
le rideau il peut y avoir un voyage aux
fidji il peut y avoir une voiture peut
aussi devant une botte de poireaux voir
d'écart entre ap alors alors qu'est-ce
que tu décides tu gardes tes cadeau et
on découvre ce que tu as perdu ou ce à
quoi tu as échappée où tu es joueuses
tu prends le raid et tu prends le rideau
des fois on a compris le rideau dans la
gueule non non tu prends le rideau tu
prendrais nous gagner cet ordinateur
portable a gagné 7 en simple tu as gagné
sa torpeur bord tu as gagné ce
smartphone et a gagné 7 facile
[Applaudissements]
a décidé de prendre le dia le rideau le
rive le rideau le river il est arrivé à
ce kabyle tu as entendu le choix
oui mais non derrière rien
exceptionnelle la gale
il faudra garder comme ça j'ai trouvé
ton rôle qu il ne prêche pas bien là-bas
europe après une longue et je sais pas
si c'est une bonne idée de faire son
devoir faire exceptionnel tu veux pas
faire un mr qui mr kais
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
et oui c'est ça et je peux sur 7 ha
meilleure émission fait l'ascension et
la wii ah non mais il a tout vu il a
tout vu de moi je retrouve le bild il ya
20 ans mais j'adore ce mec ça m'a manqué
ne peux pas te voir depuis une dizaine
d'années à la télévision merci aux élus
mais non de l'émotion il est mignon ben
fayot quand même mais bon ça pas ce qu a
fallu aux saveurs genre tu as mangé des
fayots bayoro dont le fayot je le mange
uniquement
[Applaudissements]
alors tu as pris leurs idéaux marine
attention oh là là on rappelle vincent
elle peut avoir n'importe quoi
d'ailleurs oui alors vraiment il pouvait
il peut y avoir une voiture un voyage
extraordinaire pour quatre cinq six dix
personnes mais peut aussi avoir une
botte de poireaux des carottes râpées ou
des clés de 8 ou des boulons ou des who
in roots course je crois quand même le
rideau
[Applaudissements]
m
fatras son scooter a trop peur du
sculpteur emplettes attaque repères du
scooter tu veux reprendre ça en fait non
je donne à mon père tu le donnes à ton
père qui fasse gaffe au cinéma basé ma
chérie tu as gagné scooter il faut que
la tape la droite va plus loin
c'est pas mal
[Applaudissements]